Mack we'll go find this secret file on
the new puppy we'll never get through
that door no not that door the doggy
door how do we get past the guard ah no
no no no no no no way no it she washing
walking back
[Music]
all the way down I've never been so
humiliated in all my life
[Music]
[Music]
what about doing whoa
[Music]
[Music]
no no biting
Oh watch Oh what is it
mmm gotta be near it's almost like it
begging us to go in
wow that's a lot of paperwork huh
I thought puppies shredded everything
[Music]
this is it getting creepy
I've come to yourself cut it out wait
huh that's it uh file see I wouldn't
write nope I've seen this before is the
work you've got to find something to
replace it with
how'd your I'd like another file ah yes
if I would assimilate Carroll can be
placed in the exact same position
ah okay I already said that I know I
said it oh hey really Dwight I like it a
third time
wait
[Music]
vanilla pressboard edges classic the
answer's no 49 try this one wait
now is
[Music]
ooh
yeah
I feel like we should run I know but
it's just how miss my icon would see our
game dammit
[Music]
well that didn't end well what the
temple connect we're making plans for
their newest addition what the can hear
you
but this baby has a good plan
we babies are having a crisis babies
aren't getting as much love as we used
to behold our mortal enemy oh no that's
exactly the problem
have you learned anything I see me no
what have you learned about puppies good
iced coffee
no Jimbo puppies are evil Stacey be back
for those I can't read what could say
look period oh it's like they're having
their own little meeting watch desert
humiliating you're going to write in
English John I know how important this
mission isn't the company duty I've got
a deal with the K ID yeah are you I'm on
a mission it's not enough love to go
around my job is to find out why they'll
give me a double espresso and see if it
someplace around here with decent sushi
I'd kill for a spicy tuna roll right
about now
[Applause]
hahaha
oh yeah look the kids are finally
getting along that's nice
the final succeed with this mission I
would live here forever with you okay I
will help you just to get rid of you
deal you come to Reno
no you're watching thank you okay
shoot you on that how we can pass the
guard I've never been so humiliated in
my life
[Music]
oh I don't we're not gonna be not have
it done to me what's all the racket I
did he adorable
Oh I've got one for you too what bummer
Green work the boss baby put that cookie
down
cookies offer closer
you
you